these stories just keep piling up you've
had years to think of how to respond to
this and this is the best you could do
and then he goes on to say this oh this
is what really rubbed me the wrong way
it's really like
i
reject nation what we've got here is
failure to communicate guys look so
you've probably already heard about this
by now if you have a twitter account and
we're coming to you a little bit late
and more often than not i would i would
confidently say that whenever we talk
about any story that if you like you see
the title or thumb you're like oh it's a
dramatic hate video and then i think if
you watch our videos more often than not
i would say that we would actually try
to explore a bit of a gray area and
really discuss it and talk about it or
have fun with it for the most part i'm
not gonna lie to you guys i've kind of
been uh obsessively thinking about this
story for the past few hours
and it it uh it kind of pisses me off uh
quite a bit actually it actually i'm
like i was working out at the gym
pumping out the anger just to be upfront
with you guys that's not another video
about you know restore the snyder verse
although hashtag restore the snyder
verse i don't get why it's so hard you
got a multiverse going on you could just
put in a pocket dimension it's not that
complicated and this is also not about
the future of the dc eu i mean there's
things within the dcu that i freaking
love and i'm very much excited for i'm
loving peacemaker the suicide squad is
one of my favorite movies last year the
batman i'm very much looking forward to
as well this is not even about that what
i want to talk about specifically in
solely things joss whedon said in an
interview with vulture specifically
regarding ray fisher and gal gadot so
while it's pertaining to the justice
league it's really it's really about
joss whedon and just how much of a dick
this guy is man and just how oblivious
he is to a lot of his own behaviors the
guy is a freaking narcissist this is a
classic case
of yeah i did some things wrong but most
no uh that was that's a lie that was
taken out of proportion and also uh no
they just misunderstood i just
misunderstood it and compared to a lot
of other people i'm great and after the
years of things of like ray fisher of
what he's pretty much sacrificed his
whole career about a lot of these people
have come out and told stories about
joss whedon some very abhorrent stories
about sexual misconduct just verbal
abuse emotional abuse a lot of these
people are like writers producers actors
this isn't just some person from the
street you know who is a random fan or
whatever some random fan he hooked up
with or something yeah so there's two
things here first off i like the gal
gadot one really really upsets me a lot
and i got a lot of reasons as to why
it's but i'll go into the the ray fisher
one really quick here as you guys have
heard by now the countless things you
know ray fisher has talked about of
whedon's behavior on set here's how the
article puts it we didn't downsize
cyborg's role cutting scenes that in
fischer's view challenged stereotypes
whedon says he was stunned because there
was this whole debacle about how they
were lightening up ray fisher's skin
tone color to not make him be as black
as he is right and what whedon said is
he had given the whole movie a lighter
look brightening everything in
post-production including all the faces
he said that claiming he had disliked
the character's skin tone which forbes
ultimately attracted was false and
unjust that right there i can go all
right yeah maybe the whole movie is
oversaturated so yeah sure all right
i'll give that to him but then here's
where he goes this is where i'm just
like what an [ __ ] whedon says he cut
down cyborg's role for two reasons the
storyline logically made no sense and he
felt the acting was bad what
what are you talking about none of the
claims fisher made in the media were
either true or merited disgusting whedon
told me he could think of only one way
to explain fisher's motives we're
talking about a malevolent force we're
talking about a bad actor in both senses
first of all you guys saw i'm assuming
if you're watching this video you've
seen at least zack snyder's justice
league that storyline was part made
perfect sense i remember clearly that
one of the things i was so happy about
with that movie when it came out was
that one of the most praised qualities
one of the most surprising praise
qualities for a lot of critics and
audiences was specifically the ray
fisher cyborg storyline how that was the
heart of the story and that ray fisher's
acting was incredible so to just be a
douche and just say his acting was bad
it was like no no no no you just don't
know how to direct you just don't get it
like you're not you're not getting it
you don't know how to work with the
material and what you're doing is you're
placing blame and not knowing how to
work with actors the job of a director
is to communicate that's your main job
is communicating you are the conductor
of an orchestra you're not doing
everything you're conducting you're
communicating a vision and then every
time he comes out with something it's
like nuts there if they just don't i
don't get the brilliant joss whedon he's
a bad actor he did this doesn't make any
sense and like just because it didn't
make sense to you you just say you're
acting is like this is the best you
could come up with after all these years
of ray fisher like talking about
countless specifics about your behavior
this is the best you can come up with
yeah there's a bit simplified and i mean
the one that gets me even more is just
the whole logically made no sense thing
because like at least unless it was very
very different from what we saw in the
snyder cut which i highly doubt like
yeah that that story doesn't seem to
have any more logical errors or
misnomers than any other story in the
movie and that's what seems the most
suspect to me is logically made no sense
like how and then the gal gadot one is
one that i a lot of people throw this
word around and i don't really you don't
really say this about people unless i'm
like there's
something pretty concrete about this and
the more i think about what he said here
the more i go that's kind of racist man
this is kind of racist what you said it
is very condescending to gal gadot in
this interview yeah godot didn't care
for whedon style either last year she
told reporters we didn't threaten her
and said he would make her career
miserable whedon told me he did no such
thing i don't threaten people who does
that what do you mean who does lots of
possible in hollywood like what a weird
way to people everywhere who does that
just to try to act like that's not
something that doesn't happen it's so
ignorant who does that lots of people
and then he goes on to say this oh this
is what really rubbed me the wrong way
it's really like
i oh god you can't just keep painting
[ __ ] for this
english is not her first language and i
tend to be annoyingly flowery in my
speech way to own up buddy well done he
recalled arguing over a scene she wanted
cut he told her jokingly that if she
wanted to get rid of it she would have
to tie him to a railroad track and do it
over his dead body then i was told that
i had something about her dead body and
tied her to the railroad track yeah it's
not everything that was actually said
you're focusing on one thing that was
said god do not agree with whedon's
version of events i understood perfectly
this to me does read a little bit racist
honestly gal gadot two fast and furious
movies batman be superman the zack
snyder's justice league carried wonder
woman and i'm pretty sure there wasn't
one moment in that film where i was like
what's his form [ __ ] saying i don't
know what the hell she's talking about
this one does she know what she's saying
like she speaks perfectly great english
like zack snyder justin lin patty
jenkins what's one story you can think
of where they came out and said
that's hard directing her because her
first language
it's a real problem with actors not from
america man it's really hard one i mean
you've heard joss whedon's dialogue
we've heard him talk in interviews he
can't be so flowery like if he's flowery
enough to make it so that she just
doesn't understand him then i would have
to imagine that that would happen with a
lot of other people on the set on the
crew on the cast etc it sounds like
somebody who is pretty fluent so yeah i
doubt that any any misunderstanding
would have been so significant as to
have an entire outcome effect on the
whole movie the ignorance of the
leadership position that he took over
here is what boggles my mind let's just
think about it for one second let's give
him the benefit of the doubt and go all
right he's a little flowery in his
speech
but her english isn't her first language
let's say you had like a coming from a
good place wouldn't you think wouldn't
the logical conclusion be
i need to communicate better because
english isn't her first language so i
need to be clearer and safer and maybe
get some like help to make sure
that i'm communicating what did you
think that would be the most obvious
thing to resort to i don't believe this
for one second but if that was the case
that's usually what a director has to do
these stories just keep piling up you've
had years to think of how to respond to
this and this is the best you could do
this is awful this is terrible he's such
an [ __ ] i'm at a point where i'm like
i've heard stories for years i've talked
about it for years and i'm at a point
where i'm like this guy's just a dick
plain and simple he's a dick there's a
bit in this article too that rave fisher
touches upon where he basically said you
know with zack snyder i had this uh
working dynamic where i would be able to
give him feedback and i was kind of
co-writing my character because he
wanted to make sure that the portrayal
of both just victor stone as well as him
as a black man was you know on point and
you know so trying to continue that with
joss whedon you know he was seemingly
met according to his account with pretty
solid aversion to that with josh
basically saying like hey i don't take
notes from anybody you sound like you're
giving me notes right now and that just
speaks to somebody who yeah is
very confident in their own version of
everything above everyone else's and
yeah as a director you have to have some
of that but i feel like especially
hearing him talk about gal gadot hearing
him talk about ray fisher really does
seem as though somewhere along the line
he perhaps drunk his own kool-aid and
yeah has kind of become lost in his own
power and it seems like he's very
unaware of his own behavior and a lot of
power position scenarios you know i
believe the mistreatment that a lot of
these people i can't say i believe
everyone simply because obviously
there's you know it's it's a lot of
people want like concrete evidence for
things that are intentionally done
behind closed door in secrecy that way
that you can't be
outed like that's what people do when
they're doing messed up things it's
gotten to the point where there's just
so many stories and you hear the way he
speaks on these things i've chosen a
path to believe at this point and i
believe them and especially if you're
stepping in for somebody who's already
got a huge working dynamic with these
people i think it's on you to bridge
that gap and to work with the dynamic
that you're entering that's already been
established which it doesn't seem like
he was willing to do it all nope guys
what do you think about mr joss whedon
leave your thoughts down below so you
guys can subscribe click that bell yeah
hashtag snipers
you